of all the questions we had  the one that came up most often  was  ask benedict to say the word penguin  what is this about well apparently i got  it wrong repeatedly in the documentary  and now i'm completely terrified of the  words um i don't go near it the first  one you sort of get away with and then  after that you lose all sense of what  yeah  let's let's have a look listen carefully  and the last thing you might expect to  see here  [Music]  is penguins  these are fjordland crested penguins  named after this corner of south new  zealand  so why are these woodlands so attractive  to penguins  a fresh water stream through the forest  makes a handy highway for a parent  penguin heading home from a fishing trip